- Salam, I'm Jamsheed
Al-Jamsheedi and this
is a Mideast Minute.
(orchestra music)
Villagers, thank you as
always for tuning in from
the Middle East today
as we broadcast to you
live from Springfield,
the hometown of a
number of peacekeepers.
In a recent interview,
Donald Trump suggested that
his son-in-law, Jared Kushner,
could play a pivotal role in
Middle Eastern peace talks,
leading many to accuse
Mr Trump of nepotism.
Which means it's time for
us to put Jared Kushner's
political future in context.
(dramatic music)
Villagers, Jared Kushner is not
the beneficiary of nepotism.
According to the Oxford
Dictionary, nepotism
is the practice
among those with power or
influence of favoring relatives.
And no-one in a position
of power or influence
is favoring Kushner
because he's a relative.
Especially not Trump.
He's a ruthless business man.
He puts America
first, not family.
Just listen to
Esquire's Vicky Ward.
- The Trumps are a
hermetically sealed unit.
It's family before anything,
or anyone else.
- Yes, exactly.
He puts family before
anything or anyone else,
but only because
they're qualified.
Prior to joining Trump's
political campaign,
Jared Kushner ran a
billion-dollar business.
And that's not just
the kind of thing
your family hands to you.
Here's Andrea Mitchell on MSNBC.
- [Andrea] Jared took over his
family's real estate business
when his father, Charles
Kushner, went to prison in 2005.
- Yes.
Exactly.
His family handed that to him.
But only because
Kushner was qualified.
He attended Harvard University,
one of the hardest schools
to get an admission to,
on the planet.
And it's not as if anyone just
handed his admission to him.
Here's NPR reporting on
a book by Daniel Golden.
- [Narrator] Charles Kushner
gave to charities, hospitals
and universities,
including Harvard,
which admitted Jared Kushner
after a 2.5 million dollar gift.
- Yes.
Exactly.
His family just
handed that to him.
But that doesn't mean
that he's unqualified
to broker peace between
Israel and Palestine.
Quite the opposite, he's
immensely qualified, okay.
And as Lawrence O'Donnell
reports for MSNBC,
Trump himself has outlined why.
- He said quote, Jared's
a very smart guy.
He's a quality person and I
think he can be very helpful.
- Exactly.
He's very smart.
So.
Get ready for peace.
I'm Jamsheed
Al-Jamsheedi and this
has been a Mideast Minute.